[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas näher
ich bin selbst heraus sportler und heute
zu gast im sport reporter frau korporal
jessica pilz herzlich willkommen
du bist einer der besten kenner
sportlerinnen der welt weltmeisterin
2018 gewesen und schon qualifiziert für
tokio für die olympischen spiele für die
verschobenen spiele jetzt 2 21 wie geht
es dir mit der ganzen situation mit der
verschiebung mit dem ganzen komischen
jahr 2020 wie hast du das alles
überstanden
ja es war sehr mühsam ist ja mal eine
abwechslung zu die ganzen online jahre
davor im korb weltcup saison gehabt
eigentlich nur an weltcup mit eigentlich
nur europäischer teilnahme von dem her
ja es war einfach schwierig sie ziele zu
setzen
wenn man die gustloff die wettkämpfe
stattfinden oder nicht
vor dem hera bei probiert im training
bislang sachen ausprobieren und einfach
schauen was mir gut tut und was nicht
und als jo einfach ein bisschen lockerer
seiner ist eben die jahre davor wir
hoffen natürlich dass sich 21 besser
wird es schaut ja auch schon gute aus
also dass die ganze nachrichtenlage
optimistischer wird dass wir bald eine
lösung für die pandemie haben wenn jetzt
in richtung olympia schaust du bist
schon qualifiziert es gibt einen
bewerber einen kombinations bewerb der
in dem die medaillen aus geklettert
werden
ich glaube du bist nicht ganz happy mit
dem bewerber selbst wie blickst du deine
richtung olympia er glaubte
kombinationswertung ist eigentlich keine
wirklich happy vor dem wettkampf
kletterer
man muss alle drei disziplinen klettern
und normal ist maxi moment zwar
disziplinen unterwegs gewesen davor vor
dem wir haben eigentlich alle
disziplinen komplett neu trainieren
messen und lernen müssen und es ist eine
große herausforderung und ja ich habe
die herausforderung angenommen hat mir
eben qualifiziert für tokio und wenn
jetzt voll im training in allen drei
disziplinen und welche disziplin war für
dich diejenige die du erst an lernen
muss das extra für total erstes die
disziplin der vorgabe gemacht habe und
nie trainiert habe verstehe ist eben ein
haupt disziplin
und bolt dann mache ich eigentlich ein
training immer nebenbei mit und benehmen
die wettkämpfe gestartet von dem her
sein dass man etwa disziplin wohl fühlen
kann man bei euch dann auch irgendwie
sagen von der gewichtung muss so gut
sein in dem bewerb damit man irgendwie
mehr chancen hat oder dass das mal an
die die chancen teilen sich da nicht
irgendwie entwickler ein drittel ein
drittel probe werbeaufwand und wenn man
mittelmäßig gute sind jedem dann geht
sie eine medaille aus sondern man muss
wahrscheinlich in einem bestimmten so
viel besser sein als alle anderen also
wie schaut das dann genau ausweis weißt
du das schon oder kann man schon
ungefähr ein gefühl dafür entwickeln ja
ungefähr kommen wir schon sorgen also es
ist sehr wichtig dass man an sondern
zwar stehen hat also in einer disziplin
extrem gut ist weil ihr die ergebnisse
multipliziert werden und mal eins ist
natürlich sehr gut
und ja im speed kam hat ungefähr mit
derzeit einschätzen wo man steht
daran habe auf alle fälle steht und da
90 kunden zu kümmern und mein bestes bis
jetzt 932 also muss ich noch ein
bisschen trainieren und im vorstieg ist
das heute habe ich die ganze einfach in
bestform geben weil ich bin jetzt 2018
weltmeisterin waren von dem her war sie
das ist auf alle fälle drauf habe ihn
verstehen geben in der weltspitze zu
sein ist dem speed ist die route oder
immer vorgegeben ist es immer gleich
oder verändert sich das wenn du jetzt
deine zeit genannt hast dann nämlich mal
anders das wahrscheinlich gleich oder
ähnliches damit man vergleichbare zeiten
hat oder genau also die speed router
also gibt es ein weltrekord ist genormt
ist auf der ganzen welt gleich als jeder
griff jeder tritt genau der gleichen
stelle und im eben in jedem wettkampf
gleich gutes 15 meter hoch man startet
unten mit einem stand wo man oben steht
und nach dem start egal staat immer und
oben ist an der buzzer wo man drauf hat
und dann lässt die zeit gestoppt das
schaut dafür zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer sensationell aus wenn ihr also
hinauf klettert für die sportlerinnen
und sportler selbst ist so glaube ich
gar nicht so angenehm diesen bewerb aus
zu finden ich habe in der kletterszene
immer wieder gehört naja das mit bewerb
ist eigentlich eher unbeliebt oder
stimmt das ja unter der richtigen
kletterer ist eher unbeliebt weil es
eigentlich im klettern weniger zu stören
hat es geht in richtung
lediglich laufen die richtigen speed
spezialisten die trainieren heute
eigentlich vieler in der kraftkammer
trainieren viel die beiden besten
kletterer gar nicht das heißt man muss
auch ganz andere elemente im training
ansprechen du hast auch gemeint dass die
griffe genannt ist und im sport ist
immer wieder ein thema visualisieren das
heißt du kannst wahrscheinlich wenn du
die augen zumacht und erforscht ist dass
du jetzt dahin auf erklärt das könnte
sodann genau wissen welcher griff kommt
als nächster oder musste oder sowieso
ein training an wänden ja genauso
man hat die route nicht automatisiert
also mal was genau wo jeder griff ist
und wieder griff ausschaut und wo man
greift also eben dieses abgespielt wie
immer blind die route aufgeklärt aber
verstehen dass es funktioniert das schon
gesagt im vorstieg weltmeisterin 2018
du warst da sehr jungen du bist immer
noch sehr jung
wie war das für dich dass du so früh in
deinem sport schon die weltspitze
erklimmen konnte immer sagen eigentlich
so jung peter kania film ein sporthäuser
er war schon manchen weltcup finale ist
eigentlich eine für die älteren also
ganz viele junge eigentlich im feld er
aber für dich selbst dazu wissen dass du
weltmeisterin bist wie du hast du dich
gefühlt was da durch den kopf gegangen
und vor allem weiß das was du immer
schon erreichen wollte ist hier auf alle
fälle das war gott weil die die wm heute
in innsbruck war es war heim-wm also ein
großes highlight auf alle fälle und dann
war es nochmal schöner dass wir gewinnen
kann
und es war in dem jahr einfach 2018 ist
ist große ziel bei der heim-wm einfach
in topform zu sein
aber war das erwartete also jetzt
rückblickend hätte dass du wirklich am
anfang von 2018 sagen können ich werde
zeit meisterin weil das ist absolut
realistisch oder war das auch für dich
vielleicht ein bisschen überraschung
namen vom ja was eigentlich nicht
realistisch also glauben wir trainiert
einfach auf die weltcup saison hin ja
also immer wacher dass man vorne mit
klettert aber das ist wirklich fern
siegreich das sollte man nicht dort aber
daneben
zwar glaubt zwei weltcups davor gehabt
und bei dem an wenn die zweite waren und
beim online an
erster weltcupsieg warnen vor dem er
habe dann eigentlich schon gewusst dass
das auf alle fälle medaille drinnen ist
und vielleicht sogar siegen ist glück
auf meiner seite ist ja und das hat sehr
gut funktioniert
du bist der ursprünglich aus
niederösterreich aus haag wie bist du
zum klettersport gekommen
über das ferienprogramm angefangen in
stadt habe neben verschiedenen
sportarten ausprobieren können dabei
damals neun jahre alt und da hat mir
einfach es klappt dann gefesselt mit
viel spaß gemacht und der trainer hat
eben ist talente mir gesehen und hab mir
dann regelmäßig mitgenommen zum training
und wie hast du dann entschieden dass du
das jetzt vielleicht auch berufsmäßig
machen möchtest dann war der punkt bei
dir wo du gesagt hast das ist es das
möchte ich mein ganzes leben machen oder
zumindest für diesen lebensabschnitt
machen
eigentlich so der den punkt gegeben es
hat sich einfach so entwickelt dass er
ihr mega spaß gehabt und training bin
ich regelmäßig gegangen dann habe ich
bei wettkämpfe mit macht zuerst national
dann bin ins jugendnationalteam kämen
dann bei internationalen bewerbung
gestartet und es hat sich einfach so
entwickelt und wahrheit immer eigentlich
gut dabei und die erfolgreich von dem
her kann sich einfach gereicht was hat
sich so fest und warum ich mich
fasziniert die vielfältigkeit beim
klettern also es ist einfach jeder route
jeder bürger immer unterschiedlich man
muss neue lösungen finden man steht vor
einem neuen problem und es wird einfach
nie langweilig ja und dieses lösungen
finden das musst du auch in der kroner
zeit wo das heim klettern er so in der
ersten phase nicht möglich war du kommst
du aus dem hallen erklärt an und
plötzlich hast du dich auch auf felsen
wiedergefunden wurde jetzt vor ja nicht
unbedingt dahin fast wie wahr diese
umstellung für dich nie war seltener
fels davor und irgendwie durch das die
halden dazu gehabt haben aber eigentlich
keine möglichkeit gehabt zu klettern
außerhalb auf dem feld zu gehen und vor
dem ja weiter zwar zweimal die woche
mindestens eigenen fans und hoffentlich
ein bisschen die freude wieder entdeckt
war das auch ein adäquater trainings
ersatz oder kann man gar nicht
vergleichen also dass weltkrieg
felsklettern bringt viel oder wenig fürs
für das bouldern in der halle oder ist
das vergleichbar
marco schmid werden am fels aber es ist
einfach eine andere belastung und
richtig für einen wettkampf
vorzubereiten da muss man schon in die
halle gehen zum trainieren
ihr seid ja in sozialen medien sehr
aktiv und vor allem der klettersport
sehr beliebt ich niemand schickt einen
unglaublich starken bildern die man da
so von euch sieht wenn ihr irgendwo
hängt den wildesten orten dieser welt
ist ja schon auch eine faszination für
viele dieses feld cap dann dieses
naturverbundene kannst du das
nachvollziehen oder ist das etwas wo du
wenn du nicht damit aufwächst
dieses element schwierig zu
verinnerlichen ist ich glaub schon vier
leitern und nicole zahnd oder eben im
sport nichts am hut haben für das ist
glaube ich schon sehr beeindruckend denn
wir da so felswand auf geklettert
aber er gab wenn mal bis eben den sport
bezug hat dann ist es vielleicht gar
nicht mehr so schlimm für mich sind es
ganz normale bilder eigentlich also was
ist der wildeste ort an dem sie schon
irgendwie hinaufgeklettert
wildwasserkanal es ist ja immer als
abgesichert es ist nicht gefährlich
eigentlich aber sauber außergewöhnliche
orte waren zb am windrad auf der
donauinsel auf einer felswand oder auch
wann erklärt der wand wie kommt man dazu
dass man darf ein windrad erklettert und
ja eben das angebot kriegt und ob der
zug sagt und wie war das
es war eigentlich kletterroute
aufgeschraubt mehr oder weniger und es
war sehr einfach eigentlich und der
ausblick war trotzdem sehr cool
also ist ja doch journalist auf geklappt
hat und dies auch erkennen dass er die
route war echt sehr leicht journalisten
republik wenn er das thema höhenangst
sie sich auch etwas was vielleicht in
der szene immer wieder besprochen wird
gibt es kletterinnen und kletterer die
earnings haben gibt es ist
also was für ghana was also höhenangst
kabinett auch weil eben sturz an es gibt
schon häufig haben oder berkeley im team
im nationalteam bei uns deshalb ist
einzige thema
und wie geht man damit um ich meine das
ist ja wahrscheinlich etwas das
permanent präsent ist dass man doch in
einem sport ist ja auch gefährlich sein
kann man muss ja wahrscheinlich dann
mental auch damit umgehen
wie würdest du das sehen ich glaube
gefährlich einfach nett aber es ist mir
im kopf es ist mental so manche haben es
eben gar nicht irgendwie sturz angst
mancher erwarten die können sie einfach
schwarz ist im kopf heben umzusetzen
denke ja mal also eben kein problem
damit
ich glaube man muss es einfach oft üben
einen training einbauen einfach
absichtlich eine stürzen in zeil und ich
glaube dann wird es besser
das heißt sozusagen schon simulieren wie
es ist wenn man stürzt damit man darauf
vorbereitet ist sollte es der fall sein
was man natürlich nicht hofft deine
heimatstadt hat dir ein denkmal gebaut
oder gewitter
was ist das denn genau und was bedeutet
das für dich jetzt statue als es ist
soja kletterwand simuliert und eben mit
einer kletterin drauf es ist einmal die
rede davon gewesen und das ist dann fast
ein jahr später dann realisiert worden
weil ich nicht mehr damit gerechnet und
da haben wir druck standen also es war
eine ziemliche freude und eine große
ehre für mich dass man kann auf diese
statue dann auch auf klettern habe ich
das jetzt richtig verstanden das ist
eigentlich nicht das ist steht auf einem
großen stein also auf den stein konnte
aber aufsteigen finde ich es sehr teuer
und wirst du von der menschen dann auch
darauf angesprochen wenn du wieder
daheim in die heimat bist dass da jeder
tag ein tag aus
sein denkmal sieht verleiht neben habe
ihm gefallen sein oder säuren das
gesehen haben und das ziemlich cool
finden und dann ein paar fotos
zugeschickt
aber jetzt nicht häufig du bist dann
nämlich nicht mehr bei dir zu hause der
heimat sondern bis nach innsbruck
gegangen
warum genau eigentlich wegen die
trainingsmöglichkeiten und wegen man
damals damaligen trainer wir haben viele
male trainiert früher in der schulzeit
von dem mir war es immer mein wunsch
nach innsbruck bezirken mit anderen
trainingskollegen zu trainieren und da
mein trainer dort zu haben und eben die
infrastruktur in innsbruck neuen
leistungszentrum war wahnsinn also wir
haben super trainingsmöglichkeiten warum
glaube es ist das so dass dass wir dort
sein top trainingszentrum mit allem
drumherum hab ich mein man sieht ja was
was alles herauskommt aus eurem
stützpunkt also ganz viele erfolgreiche
sportlerinnen und sportler im
klettersport was gab es das sind die
gründe
ja es seien halt bei uns eigentlich fast
alle sportler in innsbruck stationiert
istanbul trainierte verbandes töten
und es ist hat er vor ein innsbrucker
kleinere trainingshalle geben und die
ist einfach zu lang wenn also gott
mitten im breitensport dazu ist ein roll
einer kleinen halle also es ist einfach
aus allen nähten gesprungen mehr oder
weniger und da war es notwendig so große
halle zu bauen
und du bist 2016 nicht nur in innsbruck
sondern auch im herbst sportzentrum
das heißt du hast auch ganz genau wie
alle anderen heraus sportlerin herr
sportler eine grundausbildung machen
müssen
ich war diese zeit für dich unmittelbar
nach der schule dann direkt in die
grundausbildung zu gehen es war ja sehr
spannende zeit also gott das mädel kommt
mir da nur mal nett zum bundesheer und
habe nicht die möglichkeit mal die seite
kennen zu lernen eben den
grundwehrdienst und aber mit einer waffe
zu schießen oder soll es war ganz cool
ist ja es war cool erfahrung auf alle
fälle und ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie
da jetzt vom heeres sport unterstützt
werden was hast du mitnehmen können für
dich persönlich menschlich auch für den
sport aus dieser zeit
wir sind ja doch anstrengende wochen sag
ich jetzt mal und dann die erste zeit in
den stützpunkten selbst was hat dich da
vielleicht längerfristig auch geprägt
gmbh monat lang und ausbildung gehabt
im fall der fälle disziplin gelernt
ordnung zu halten also ich habe ja
vorher fälle mitgenommen
gerade jetzt wo er lernen in
in einer wohnung wohnen ich sah mich
dass wir die ordnung hat das heißt viele
elemente die wir essentiell sind jetzt
wie die ganzen massen testungen waren
hast du mir im vorgespräch erzählt dass
ihr auch als sportlerinnen und sportler
teilgenommen habt wie hast du diese
erfahrung wahrgenommen haben wir im
verband ausgehen müssen weil immer
regelmäßige kontrollen neben im training
anstehen
da haben wir die chance genutzt und wild
wieder normaler carola das natürlich
nicht angenehm aber es ist wichtig dass
man sie dessen lassen oder einfach die
gewissheit hat dass man gesund ist
wenn du jetzt auf dieses jahr blickt und
haben jetzt auch schon olympia
angesprochen wie würde ein optimales
jahr verlaufen von der planung wie ihr
euch das vorgestellt habe sich das
konzept auch die wettkämpfe in richtung
tokio selbst
wir haben jetzt schon voll im training
und mein plan ist eigentlich dass sie in
jeder disziplin weltcup starter es geht
im april los bei uns und geben dann
schauen wir dass sie bei den weltcups
gute ergebnisse bringen und dann bis
juli/august vol.at drei disziplinen
fokussieren dass jetzt die drei
disziplinen noch mal angesprochen
es gab eine entscheidung vom ioc also
vom internationalen olympischen
exekutive komitee das sportklettern im
programm von 20 24 uhr paris dabei sein
wird und vor allem mit zwei bewerben das
ist glaube ich etwas was dir entgegen
kommt wie schaut das in richtung paris
dann vom programm aus bei euch ja es ist
sehr erfreulich weil es eben zwei
medaillen entscheidungen gibt
speed dieser einzeldisziplin und es gibt
dann die kombination aus buldern und
lied das heißt eben speedfight weg für
mich und der folge verließ große ziel
dann mit dafür zu qualifizieren und eben
in der kombination aus buldern bohlen
und lied zu starten
das heißt du müsstest auch wieder im
training elemente umstellen oder das
ganze speedtraining weglassen oder
würdest du dann auch im speed bewerb
einzeln antreten oder ich freue mich
eigentlich schon sehr auf die zeit noch
tokio 20 21 weil eben speed training
endlich wieder weglassen kann also das
ist echt nett so das was mir freude
macht und vor dem mehr freuen wenn eben
die speed disziplin weg was mache ich
wenn du nicht gerade irgendwo an einer
wand hengste und trainierst du benutzt
du deine zeit was tust du alle sind da
noch freizeit gern eigentlich kaffee
trinken also mit freunden noch billigere
sachen eigentlich in meiner freizeit
west training ist anstrengend ist aber
sonst so als ausgleichssport gehe gerne
einmal auf dem berg oder laufen oder so
gibt es unbedingt einen ort auf dem du
hoch erklärt dann möchtest du in deiner
karriere oder später nachher also gibt
es unbedingt einen punkt wo du
hinaufklettern möchtest navi eigentlich
kann im kopf was es gibt ja sogar
reiseziele wohin möchte sie zum fest
klettern
aber das ist jetzt nicht so alpin
sondern mehr zum sportklettern es heißt
river gold in amerika zum beispiel
sondern möchte unbedingt immerhin und
darum genau warum gedauert weil die
wände ganz coole farben haben und echte
coole fotos gesehen habe und sie ist
einfach sein reiseziel wärme und das
wird dann wahrscheinlich auch öfters
instagram konto gute bilder geben
ihr seid ja sehr sehr beliebt auf den
sozialen plattformen hat auch
international affairs im vergleich zu
anderen sportlerinnen und sportlern in
österreich hat die kletterszene eine
sehr große follower schafft und man
glaubt so liegt das ja ich glaube wir
haben einfach extrem gute internationale
community also klettern ist einfach in
fast jedem land weltweit bekannt
nordamerika ist asien afrika eben europa
also eigentlich haben wir relativ wenig
verlor vor österreich sondern einfach
international und ja es ist einfacher
trendsportart ist merkt man
und das macht den sport dadurch auch
natürlich
attraktiv für verschiedene menschen dass
sie dann auch vielleicht mit dem sport
anfangen
was würdest du zum beispiel jungen
menschen erwarten warum sie mit dem
klettersport anfangen sollten es macht
einfach extrem spaß man braucht nicht
viel gebracht hat lettershop und schock
und konnte ich mir im bouldern schon
loslegen
man braucht kann cool ist eigentlich
dafür und die nächste kletterhalle gehen
und den sport ausprobieren und es macht
einfach spaß mal steht vor dem problem
probiert es zu lösen und es geht in
allen schwierigkeitsgraden ist es auch
jetzt was glaubst du was man dann im
eigenen leben mitnehmen kann also dieses
dieses problem lösungsorientiert hat
oder hast du dir dann noch keine
gedanken gemacht
ich denke dass es einem im alltag
irgendwie umsetzbar ist eben probleme
lösen geduld haben und ja da für die
kreative die kreativität glaube ganz gut
du hast noch einige jahre im sport vor
ort aber wenn du jetzt in die zukunft zu
blicken müsst das wofür hast du dich
genau sehen
das ist ganz schwarzem sorgen immer weiß
ja nie was kommt ich hoffe dass ich
verletzungsfrei bleibt und 20 24 zb sein
großes ziel und hat ja die ganzen welt
cups in den nächsten versionen
ich schaue einfach was kommt dass ich
immer noch mal keine großen gedanken da
gab es irgendwie einen traumberuf einen
wunschberuf den unbedingt einmal haben
wo möchtest oder oder sein möchtest ja
eigentlich nur dass ich bin ganz
zufrieden jetzt mit neben sport und ja
er ist auf alle fälle im klettersport
eigentlich bleiben und haben ist eben
als athlet los vielleicht dass trainer
oder ja mal schauen muss der kinder
wo würdest du sagen sind deine talente
also deine stärken wenn es um sport geht
aber auch vielleicht menschlich und im
alltag im sport elemental eigentlich
ziemlich stark und aberglaube aktuelle
technik für den sport also gab es in so
many größten stärken und als mensch
im echten leben ich glaube kann relativ
gut zu hören als ich bin nicht so die
plaudertasche ich denke es ist meine
große stärke
was mich immer interessiert und
fasziniert ist wo sich viele
sportlerinnen und sportler selbst sehen
würden wenn sie nicht in ihrem sport
gelandet wären sondern in einer anderen
sportart wenn du nicht im klettersport
gelandet erst wo hättest du dich auf
jeden fall erfolgreich gesehen weil es
ganz schwarz bezogen
als mir schon immer viele sportarten
spaß gemacht da war was man sonst liegt
wüsste jetzt nicht keine ahnung hast
keine andere sportart die duh irrsinnig
gerne noch neben dem schießsport
betreibt jedoch nie geben schon gerne
laufen oder so aber auch dass jetzt viel
mehr gereicht hätte
und auf jeden fall kettern
abwechslungsreicher ich habe ja noch
stehen dass deine großen leidenschaften
kochen und backen sind ist etwas wo du
viel zeit hinein investiert
neben dem pferd dann viel zeit wird
jetzt nicht sagen aber eben an einem
bause dass er mehr einen kuchen backen
oder so was ist da dann der
lieblingsrezept zwar immer
unterschiedlich also bananen brot gibt
es ja oft sonst muffin saison ganz ganz
unterschiedlich eigentlich das heißt
eine familie profitiert wenn du einmal
daheim bist auch von deinen backe
künsten stichwahl familie
welchen stellenwert hat familie für dich
spürst du die unterstützung von seiner
familie
also mir ist die familie schon sehr
wichtiger sei es mit dem telefonieren
eigentlich regelmäßig also haben wir
immer gut heute media und aber wenn
irgendwelche probleme oder sorgen oder
sonst irgendwas haben wie man sie wenden
und ja eben wenn sie das training
erlaubt vorher gern einmal am wochenende
noch niederösterreich und ja besuche
meine eltern und meine katze in einer
nicht so oft
mitgenommen nachdem sneijder nadel ist
auch in der wohnung des wieder nicht
also besser aufgehoben
bei deinen eltern ist dass das hast du
jetzt machst auch das was deine eltern
sich für dich vorgestellt haben oder
hatten sie eigentlich ein anderer plan
für dein leben oder hat dass du immer
komplett die offenheit dass du selbst
entscheiden
na die haben wir da eigentlich bei dem
was ich gemacht habt ihr einfach die
wollten einfach immer dass ihr das
machen was man sagt und habe mir da
einfach unterstützt so gut gegangen ist
also ich glaube zufrieden bin und happy
bin dann war es sehr nah und solange du
zufrieden und hätte bist du bist du auch
erfolgreich und danke dir auf jeden fall
für die einblicke in deiner karriere in
deine gedanken und ich wünsche dir noch
viel erfolg für die zukunft und
natürlich viel gesundheit was auf dich
auf und danke dass du bei uns im sport
report fasst danke euch ja fürs zuhören
und zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]